he's an American businessman investor
self-help author and motivational
speaker he's the founder of the Rich Dad
company he has an estimated net worth of
80 million dollars he's Robert Kiyosaki
and here are his top ten rules for
success so the last thing I want to talk
about debt is one of the best
investments I made because I started off
with no money like most people you know
my first investment was a little 18,000
dollar condo in Hawaii and I made a
whopping 25 dollars a month I didn't
make much money on that deal but every
time I did an investment be it real
estate or business
I got smarter because experience makes
you smarter so I started with just a
little eighteen thousand dollar unit I
broke up my credit card I paid the two
thousand dollar down payment with my
credit card so 100% financed now most
experts will tell you that's stupid you
don't do that but but if you know what
you're doing you can do it a number of
years ago I bought a 7 million dollar
commercial building I paid for it with
zero down and every month after
everything is paid for it puts about
$30,000 a month income in my pocket or
three hundred sixty thousand dollars a
year for no money down so that is the
price of having a good education or a
bad education a good education is
knowing the good debt versus bad debt
and how debtors can win if you know what
you're doing I don't know what the heck
with people think about money but that's
what I get a lot of is kind of this well
you know money is not spiritual I'm just
saying it's your attitudes you know the
person's attitude towards money I make a
lot of money but I give a lot you know
what I mean in fact it goes to biblical
principle the more you give the more you
receive so when I meet somebody who's
not doesn't have any money it just means
that they're not giving something yeah
you know so a lot of times there's
people who would like more but they're
not giving anything so they're like my
poor debt you know he belonged to the
labor unions and he wanted to work less
and get paid more well that's
anti-religious to me
yeah if you want to get paid more work
more give more that's how I see it
discipline I had to get into was always
pay myself first even when I had no
money and would have all these bill
collectors calling me I use them as
inspiration really Oh wonder how the
government's hounding you bill
collectors calling it because I've been
broke again you understand what it feels
like to be broke
when those guys are calling you instead
of you know shrinking and going into the
shell and eating my pizza I use it as
motivation to go out and make more money
so I used that I used my bill collectors
as motivation and that's why I paid
myself first even though sometimes I
would you pay yourself I was blunt
assets I buy a house or I'd put money in
the bank and things like this but it was
just a habit
look what exact what you're talking
about it's up here it's about changing
the way you think you said the whole
book is about that's because we're our
biggest asset we're also my biggest
liability but the common wisdom the old
intelligence idea is to diversify and
what I believe in this is something else
is increase your financial IQ you
financial like intelligence and instead
focus and what focus stands for is this
focuses follow one course till you're
successful and so that's what I did in
1973 I signed up for my first real
estate investment course and I just did
it and did it and did it you know I
bought this one little $18,000 place and
I did it again and I did it again and I
did it again until the point where I
understood it and then I went into
becoming an entrepreneur and I did it
and I did it and did it I'm still
learning and I'm still learning about
real estate and the reason 1966 I got
into oil when I went to work for the
Standard Oil Company so today I'm still
focusing I invest in oil and oil and oil
and I don't diversify you know doesn't
mean they don't lose sometimes I'm lose
sometimes I make mistakes and all this
but I just don't buy good as with all
the bad if you're going to be successful
as an investor do you know
diversification is good for the average
investor that's what you want to be have
a good life but what I'd rather do is be
able to know the good ones from the bad
ones the good investments for the bad
investments the good advisors from the
bad advisors and what's good for me and
what's not good for you
because what I do is not necessarily
what's going to work for you and vice
versa later so that's why I really think
instead of diversification or
diversifying the new rules of money say
follow one course until you're
successful and then keep doing it
because once you find that way of being
successful you can do it again and again
and again the thing is you see when
people economies go out become is go
down we might go into a depression
the worldwide like I said I Francis it
very big trouble Germany is okay
England's in big trouble
China's in trouble so if we go that we
go to a worldwide depression that might
take ten years you know to come out of
it but during these times is the best
time I have made more money in the last
three years than ever before in my life
you know I bought five I bought five
golf courses last year on a bank that's
impressive
well the bankses yeah Donald bought ten
they're giving them away no I'm totally
yeah but you have to know how to operate
them you know yeah ethic an entrepreneur
yeah so the bank's just call you up and
they say that there was this one it was
five golf courses in one hotel in the
states in Arizona yeah golf Mecca you
know and but this Japanese company had
it and they asked me if I want to buy it
about five years ago for 260 million I
said does it make sense you know it
doesn't make sense at 260 million so
they told me I didn't know what I was
doing this I'll get by and then lasts
this one year ago the summer the city
bank called up and says you want lost
golf courses and they gave me the money
to buy him just to reiterate was in
nineteen price of 1975 I came out with
this product and we're extremely
successful but we kept running out of
money but the more successful we got the
more we ran out of money so that's when
I went to my Rich Dad I tried to borrow
$100,000 and he chewed me out he says
why would I invest in a dumb product
when you have a bad business and so
that's what that's when he began teach
me the next level of my entrepreneurial
education it's not about the product
it's about how to design a business that
doesn't need me to keep raising the
capital in other words how you design a
business that keeps raising money
automatically and today that Rich Dad
company is cash rich cash keeps pouring
in
because the ability to raise money
constantly was designed into the
business and once again this is the
diagram this is the BI triangle these
are the eight pieces that make up a
business when a business is hurting
oftentimes is because one of these eight
pieces is missing for example many times
people to have a great product but their
legal is really bad or this
communication systems are bad or they're
on it you know their internal order
processing is a bad or the manufacturing
is bad or the marketing is bet and they
only have bad cash flow management
another part
of your financial IQs - no there's three
types of income so if you're gonna say
it work hard most people are working
hard for earned income and that's what
these guys are working for the trouble
with earned income in America
tax rates approximately fifty percent or
as warren buffett says is a shame that
his secretary pays a higher percentage
in taxes and he did although he makes
billions of dollars so when you say to a
child go to school and get a safe secure
job you're telling the word for earned
income the worst type of income the
second type of income is portfolio
income and today as I speak and they're
trying to change this it's about 20
percent in portfolio income is generally
known as capital gains if I buy a stock
for ten dollars and I sell it for $50
the $40 gain is taxed at 20% or if I buy
a house for a hundred thousand I sell it
for two hundred thousand that's a
capital gains type of event so you pay a
lot of tax for that and the third type
of income which is the which is the best
type of income excuse me I can't spell
again it's passive income and this is
income that just comes in on a regular
basis one of the reasons I am wealthy
and is able to retire at a young age is
because I worked hard for passive income
not earned income I don't flip real
estate generally not portfolio income I
don't flip stocks I want passive income
so today the new rules of money is
important to understand what are you
going to school to become es
entrepreneur or investor and what kind
of income you're working hard for earned
portfolio or passive and if you know
what you're doing you can pay zero
pratense percent taxes legally and this
can be done all over the world people
saying we can't do it in my country well
these people can't do it in any country
but in most parts of the world
governments need these people so they're
always giving tax incentives for for
investors and business owners who are
for passive income so those are some of
the new rules of money you've really got
to know what you're working hard at and
what kind of work are you performing
what kind of income are you working hard
for well most successful
entrepreneurs have gone bust yeah you
know Henry Ford an old-time entrepreneur
he went bust five times okay look look
at Steve Jobs yep his own board fired
him yeah you know Bill Gates was taken
before the Supreme Court for
monopolistic practices right here my
friend Donald Trump went down a billion
dollars yeah I only went down a million
so the average person is so afraid of
those losses they never get ahead
because at school they teach you if you
make a mistake or if you fail you're a
failure but that's not real life a baby
learns to walk by standing up and
falling down standing up and falling
down and our school system punishes you
for making mistakes that's why my poor
dad an academic was so unsuccessful he
was terrified of making mistakes but key
to raising money this is Ken McElroy's
company it's called MC companies Ken
McElroy's business is in the business of
acquiring assets
that's why his company gets richer and
richer and richer every year he adds
probably a thousand new apartment units
to his inventory so Ken's company gets
richer and richer because MC core
company is designed to increase assets
poorly designed businesses never have
any assets they have huge liabilities I
trust that makes sense to you so Ken
macro is business gets stronger and
stronger and stronger because every year
she's increasing more assets the Rich
Dad company get stronger and stronger
and stronger because every year we add
more assets this year we're adding
franchising to a mix we're also you know
rich brother rich sister the book has
come out we come out with the real book
of real estate etc etc and every one of
those products every year continues to
send money into our product so that's an
idea of a well designed business if you
have a well designed business I don't
care it's for real estate or making you
know cash flow boardgames
if it's well designed investors will put
give money to you because this is a well
designed business
I think the big mistake is I hear so
many people say it's important to save
that's ridiculous and the reason that's
ridiculous is because what happened in
1971 is crucial in 1971 the US dollar
stop being money in 1971 the US dollar
became a currency and what that meant is
Richard Nixon in 1971 the president took
us off the gold standard that's like
giving an alcoholic free rein to the bar
or it's like giving somebody we can't
control their spending unlimited credit
cards so what's happening is all the
savers today are losers you know the
problem with 1971 is that the federal
government keeps printing money so the
value of your money keeps going down so
these people I'm saving saving saving
and if you notice as the value of the
dollar goes down prices go up so they
call this inflation you know you look at
in 1997 oil was about I think $10 a
barrel ten years later it's about a
hundred thirty five a barrel so they say
it's inflation but really what it is is
the dollars value coming down so savers
are getting wiped out today so just keep
saying to yourself and to your kids to
save money that is not the new rule
that's an old rule so a very big problem
for most people to stop using the word
save and use the word hedge you've got
to hedge your money hedge against losses
like when I buy a stock I put a hedge
and I put a stop loss or a put inside of
it or a call whatever I'm doing I want
to stop it so today I don't save money
I'm hedging so I in 1997 I started
investing in oil gold and silver so as a
dollar drop oil gold and silver went up
so I'm not betting so much on oil gold
and silver I'm bidding against the US
dollar and that's why this idea that
you're going to tell people you need to
save money that's really really an
obsolete idea because the idea went
obsolete in 1971 the US dollar in the
last few years has lost almost 80% of
its purchasing power and the prediction
is because this has happened throughout
history it happened thousands of years
ago with the Romans with the Greeks with
the Germans with the English the
Japanese and the Chinese every time
they've made money money into a currency
something you could print and unlimited
every time they have that has happened
the currency has gone to its true value
which is zero so I am afraid as this
economic volatility continues the savers
who were operating by the old rules of
money are just gonna get wiped out
because the purchasing power of their
dollar is going to go down so even with
a bank paying you five to ten percent
interest you can't keep up with the
bank's printing money so that's the old
rule of money is saving money and the
new rule is hedge you've got to be able
to see what's coming up as something
else is coming down thank you so much
for watching I made this video because
the B thong asked me to so if there's a
famous entrepreneur that you want me to
profile next leave it in the comments
below and I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Robert
Kiyosaki's top ten rules had the biggest
impact on you leave it in the comments
below and I'm gonna join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
beam to believe and I'll see you soon